I uh I go to bars to meet girls that's  my move I notice there's a lot of girls  at the bar these days flirting with guys  just for the free drinks you know  they're not going to put out but they  want those drinks pretty good move makes  you wonder you think there's ever been  any smart kids out there who would flirt  with pedophiles just for the candy  now you're like hey Timmy don't talk  that guy he's a child molester I know  what I'm doing  yeah I gotta get these Skittles somehow  all right  half of you are enjoying this half of  you look terrified  these are just jokes calm down uh  they're just words people are [ __ ]  animals these are syllables  um  uh cool all right  yeah comedy pedophiles what a creepy  group huh yeah creepy is a fun word huh  because it's a word that changed with  age like to a kid creepy is like a like  a haunted house to an adult creepy he's  like a guy on a bus who Winks at you  while eating a banana